[Music]
1 2 3
4 is our you
[Applause]
ready um I've never even conceived D of
a con something like this before I
didn't even know that anyone did
anything like this so obviously stays
true to the Roo very Innovative it's
it's very fun it's not supposed to be
stressful um and nothing is ever like
that serious it's totally new um this is
the first time I've dressed up like this
in a few years probably getting a bit of
the cold feet but no I'm mostly really
excited go and grow it's just exciting
to get the opportunity to just see how
that actually plays out in a little bit
more of a high stick scenario I think I
think I'll just bring a good spirit to
the team and I think to really get to
the right answer you have to be willing
to have the courage to to descend and
that's a thing that I I generally try to
bring to the
team I'm looking forward to killing it
in this competition with my awesome
squadmate Helen be supportive and direct
uh in our feedback and and and really
just look forward to learning from them
actually I excited to be with the squad
it feels like the whole quarter has kind
of been leading up to this I'm excited
to meet the alumni who are coming to
work with us today it's hard I mean it's
not easy like you know uh especially
with people you don't know and they're
in theory distinguished alumni uh
they're kind of judging you yeah it's a
little nerve-wracking I like to try to
make things a little bit spicy think if
everyone's too nice then it becomes
boring so it's good to try to play out
the mean side a little bit take the
learnings from here in the US at a US
University and apply them in Africa and
also teach other people as well kind of
what I've learned I think is one of my
goals I think the executive challenge is
going to be challenging it's going to be
fun I think we're going to meet a lot of
uh Executives that come from different
backgrounds in different Industries and
challenge Us in different
ways I hope we come out on top you know
we'll see I think we have some
confidence in ourselves I'd hope we'd
come out on top and what's really cool
as a judge is to hear a team of people
approach a problem in you know six
different ways over the course of the
day I just felt like I learned so much
in the day itself we dedicating
ourselves to this full day of um of the
challengeing exercise I'm looking
forward to everything this is the reason
I came to GSB and I'm excited to get
together with my squad and to show what
we're made of and everything we've been
working on and really excited to crush
the competition as well something that I
learned at Stanford is how powerful it
is to just get and hang out with people
around you there are so many incredible
people I honestly think it was the the
most valuable two years of my life right
being here and it was the experiential
learning that that really did a lot of
that for me we've been able to role play
with each other before I've been able to
know out we get a bit more not only uh
in class but also in these role plays so
I feel like it's a chance for us to
build on that opportunity even 25 years
after I came here it still makes me
think about kind of uh how the world has
changed and uh and how to approach uh
situations differently I actually was
part of the group that piloted the
executive challenge the first year and
have been judging almost every year
since it was amazing um it
was more than I expected but it also
very an actual board meeting lots of
positives and lots of things that I want
to continue to work on think oh it was a
blur like I'm still trying to figure out
what happened I think like the biggest
takeaway for me was how nuanced they
were in each of their responses and they
were all complimenting each other so we
got like a very holistic picture of how
we should be responding how we should be
working in such situations and that was
really really beneficial we knew it' be
tough but I guess it was even even
tougher than we thought yeah students
were terrific and uh one of them even
went was able to get straight to um
getting the ask and that's really hard
to do and and getting our input early on
also hard to do he did amazing yeah he
also did an amazing job no it it was
honestly pretty fun uh a lot more
collaborative than I thought it was
going to be and she AED it awesome so
yeah I was glad to have her as a partner
yeah I'm just amazed like like that's
why I fly back out here to do this every
year it it you you really understand
what the GSB is doing for these folks
for me it was very interesting to see if
I'm effective in that environment and to
take the lessons that I've learned
through the class and determine what I
want to continue doing going forward
what changes I want to make and how I
can be the most effective leader as I go
for past graduation I did this about 10
years ago so I still remember some of
the lessons I took away from my
experience and doing the executive
Challenge and even some small things
that show up and how I show up as a
leader everything was
surprising I thought like 50% of it was
surprising
um I thought the the alumni asked you
know tough questions if I had to give
them advice I think one of the best
things they can
do it's really about your ability to
connect with your audience oh you you
you must put us in there hearing the the
alums feedback right after of phrases
they would use or different strategies
to kind of push the conversation along
was really really really
[Applause]
impactful
if I win I'm going to Disney
World 1 2 3
[Music]